5 55
on your friday morning a ramp opening
update and more from
where else the 95 in the northern 215
beltway you got it we're going
centennial bowling
so the final freeway to freeway flyover
bridge in the centennial bowl was
tentatively scheduled to open next month
but i just learned from
nevada department of transportation
spokesman tony ilya that that
has been pushed back to the end of the
year
if you drive there regularly you know
i'm talking about the connector from the
south 95 to the east 215
and like many of the changes in all our
lives this is pandemic related but
the ultimate project completion finish
line of 2024
has not changed oh and that other tidbit
from tony concerns one of the pictures
we showed you last week about the
expansion of sky point
a big step forward for that the pouring
of the top
deck for what will be known as john
herbert boulevard
fact tony says a crew of 30 workers and
two
pump trucks poured 902 cubic yards of
concrete
delivered by 90 mixer truck trips during
the overnight hours just this morning
now the online version of this story
includes more about the fellow
that part of skypoint will be renamed
for mr herbert and there are links to
all of our centennial bowl stories at
eightnewsnow.com when you click traffic
then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and please put on their phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com